érase una vez una bella princesa dormida
por la maldición de una bruja vengativa
todos sabemos cómo termina este cuento
cuando el apuesto príncipe consigue
llegar hasta la princesa y con su beso
la despierta y por supuesto la princesa
que hay inmediatamente rendida de amor a
sus pies bueno los cuentos cuentos son y
en las antípodas estos relatos
imaginarios encontramos las
elaboraciones de la ciencia los cuentos
son el mundo de la fantasía y la ciencia
es el mundo de los hechos y sin embargo
el cuento de la bella durmiente' se coló
inadvertidamente en la representación
científica de la fecundación sexual el
óvulo yace inerte hasta que el más
intrépido y veloz de los espermatozoides
que lo cortejan consigue llegar hasta él
el primero atraviesa su muro y lo activa
para dar comienzo a una nueva vida esta
proyección de lo que son ideas
culturales sobre lo masculino y lo
femenino lo que hizo fue de algún modo
obstaculizar la investigación sobre los
mecanismos activos que tiene el óvulo
para captar a los espermatozoides y
también sobre el proceso de los procesos
de capacitación que el espermatozoide
experimenta una vez que está ya dentro
del tracto genital femenino hoy en día
los módulos los óvulos
lo mismo que las más modernas princesas
de disney ya tienen iniciativa propia y
además están bien despiertos la ciencia
nos proporciona el conocimiento más
fiable que tenemos que los humanos hemos
desarrollado sobre el mundo que
habitamos pero la ciencia lo que no
puede hacer es ofrecernos verdades que
sean simples e inapelables un buen
ejemplo de esto lo proporciona la
primatología descubrir las vidas y los
mundos de estos parientes cercanos
nuestros los orangutanes los babuinos
los bonobos los chimpancés es una tarea
absolutamente fascinante pero descubrió
su mundo nunca fue únicamente esto
porque a menudo lo que se buscaba al
estudiar a los primates era encontrar
claves para entender el comportamiento
de los primeros homínidos un patrón
primate que nos ayudará en definitiva a
conocernos mejor a nosotros mismos y por
eso louis leakey el famoso
paleoantropólogo a mediados del siglo 20
promovió la investigación en
primatología lic y pensaba además que
las mujeres íbamos a ser mejores
primatólogas porque tenemos mayor
capacidad para la empatía bueno yo no sé
si liquid tenía tenía razón con esto
pero el caso es que las mujeres que él
reclutó
jane goodall biruté galdikas diane
fossey con su ejemplo narrado a través
de los documentales de la national
geographic se convirtieron en modelos y
sirvieron como ejemplo para que muchas
otras chicas muchas otras jóvenes se
despertarán ella es la vocación por la
primatología y siguieran sus pasos por
eso también la primatología es una
ciencia muy peculiar porque en ella
encontramos a muchas mujeres muchas más
que en otras disciplinas científicas en
las que a veces es muy difícil pensar en
grandes científicas en mujeres
relevantes más allá de la ubicua marie
curie cuando ellas van a las selvas las
sabanas las montañas los bosques a
observar a los primates la imagen que
teníamos acerca de estos parientes
nuestros se parecían mucho a la de los
personajes estereotipados de los cuentos
los machos eran tarzanes que lo que
hacían era conseguir comida para el
grupo defenderlos de los ataques
externos y competían entre ellos por los
favores de las hembras y las hembras
básicamente eran criaturas maternales
que estaban dedicadas en cuerpo y alma a
la crianza y disponible sexualmente para
los machos
ellas cuando van a las selvas y a las
sabanas lo que nos ofrecen es una imagen
muchísimo más compleja de las hembras de
los machos y de las relaciones entre
ellos que estos estereotipos de
príncipes valientes y princesas
desvalidas de los cuentos y al volver
más compleja la imagen que tenemos de
los primates lo que ocurre también es
que se va volviendo cada vez va
perdiendo cada vez más sentido esta idea
de mirarnos en ellos como un espejo
porque ahora cada primate cada individuo
y cada especie primate incluida la
especie humana es única y tiene valor
propio
jane goodall no solamente nos descubrió
que los chimpancés como especie eran
capaces por ejemplo de usar instrumentos
como piedras para abrir frutos secos o
ramitas para meterlas en un termitero y
comercia las termitas o que eran capaces
de transmitir cultura también nos
desveló que los comportamientos
agresivos de los machos no significaban
realmente que ellos fueran los que
mandarán porque por ejemplo la chimpancé
flow de un modo mucho más sutil era
capaz de ocupar un papel relevante en la
organización social del grupo y además
transmitir a sus hijas este estatus que
ella alto que ella tenía en la sociedad
de gombe jane goodall fue capaz de ver
lo que otros no habían visto antes
porque ella entendió que cada miembro
del grupo era un individuo que era
interesante por sí mismo y que las
hembras no eran simplemente recursos un
recurso más en unas sociedades dirigidas
por los machos además al extender en el
tiempo el trabajo de campo
la propia gudal y también las sucesoras
de las mujeres las primatólogas que
trabajaron con ella nos ofrecieron una
descripción muchísimo más acertada de
los comportamientos de las hembras las
hembras ahora
y buscaban activamente parejas sexuales
luchaban por mantener sus jerarquías
dentro del grupo e incluso eran capaces
hasta de cometer infanticidio con las
crías de otras hembras cuando solamente
miramos a lo que salta a la vista a
menudo podemos estar perdiendo nos lo
realmente interesante y esto fue lo que
les ocurrió a los primeros primatólogos
cuando fueron a las sabanas a observar a
los babuinos lo que vieron en primer
plano
fueron las peleas y las reyertas de los
machos y entonces en el mundo de la
guerra fría ellos elaboraron una
narrativa de acuerdo con la cual las
vidas de los babuinos dependían de la
estructura jerárquica de sus machos y
estos machos eran individuos que eran
terriblemente agresivos que bueno
competían entre ellos finalmente por las
hembras y sin embargo eran capaces de
comportarse como una tropa muy bien
disciplinada cuando se trataba de
proteger al grupo de un ataque de un
enemigo externo
pero cuando la primatóloga thelma rowell
fue a la sabana lo que vio tenía muy
poco que ver con esta imagen
militarizada ella vio que los machos no
eran tan agresivos que las hembras no
estaban simplemente sentadas esperando
que llegara su príncipe azul que era las
relaciones entre las hembras las que
realmente estructuraban la organización
del grupo y que las hembras además
estaban súper ocupadas consiguiendo
comida para sus retoños o cultivando las
amistades que les iban a ser más
favorables para ayudar a su prole al en
el futuro su prole otras primatólogas el
modelo militar entonces de los babuinos
fue poco a poco desmontándose y otras
primatólogas como ya en alemán como
shirley strum bárbara schmutz también
contribuyeron a desmontar otras ideas
muy arraigadas por ejemplo la idea de
que los machos dominantes tienen un
acceso prioritario a las hembras y por
tanto hay más crías del grupo que son
hijas suyas ella es lo que nos
descubrieron es que el macho más
fanfarrón no era realmente el que más
llegaba y que las hembras apreciaban
muchísimo la cualidad de la discreción a
la hora de elegir con quien aparearse
montar esta nueva imagen de los babuinos
requería mirar en segundo plano lo que
ocurría más allá de las ruidosas puertas
de los machos y esto por ejemplo y en
alemán lo hizo elaborando protocolos
sistemáticos de observación que
asegurarán que garantizarán que cada
individuo cada miembro del grupo iba a
ser observado y no solamente aquellos
que fueran más ruidosos o llamarán más
la atención
precisamente la vida sexual de los
primates es también un grandísimo
ejemplo de la fuerza que tienen las
creencias para dirigir nuestras
observaciones y la interpretación de las
mismas durante mucho tiempo la idea
tradicional era que la iniciativa sexual
era una cuestión únicamente de los
machos y las hembras se dudaba incluso
se debatía acerca de si las hembras de
los primates disfrutaban con el sexo y
si tenían incluso orgasmos cuando nunca
se discute acerca de si los machos
tenían orgasmos pero el trabajo de amy
parís con los bonobos o el trabajo de
saraja hardy con los langures nos
descubre que las hembras son individuos
que buscan activamente el sexo y que
además para ellas
sexo no solamente importante por su
papel en la reproducción para sara hard
y el sexo para los primates es también
placer y estrategia porque el disfrute y
ha sostiene sada hard y que el disfrute
que el orgasmo les provoca a las hembras
de los primates las incentiva a tener
relaciones con muchos machos y esto en
definitiva la ventaja que tiene es la de
preservar a sus crías porque a menudo
los machos lo que hacen es matar a las
crías que no son suyas para provocar que
las hembras estén gama están amamantando
entren de nuevo en celo y de este modo
las crías eran se mantenían de algún
modo a salvo
esta imagen de los primates como
individuos que son activos sexualmente
contrasta terriblemente con la imagen
que habíamos tenido tradicionalmente
acerca con la explicación tradicional
acerca de por qué las hembras porque las
hembras humanas tenemos orgasmos lo que
se decía tradicionalmente es que las
hembras humanas tenemos orgasmos porque
reforzó esto refuerza en el vínculo
monógamo en la pareja de tal modo que
las hembras las mujeres ofrecemos a los
hombres acceso ilimitado al sexo y ellos
a cambio lo que nos proporciona lo que
nos ayudan es a cuidar a nuestras hijas
entonces hará haarde y lo que hace es
darle la vuelta a esta relato
tradicional y convertir las hembras que
eran pasivas y eran fieles convertirlas
en hembras asertivas y promiscuas lo que
creemos que somos y como creemos que
debemos ser en estos relatos de
adaptación aparece de algún modo ligado
necesariamente por la fuerza que tiene
la evolución para definirnos estas
transformaciones que las primatóloga se
introdujeron en los métodos en las
teorías científicas lo que nos
demuestran es que el punto de vista de
la perspectiva es realmente importante
ellas con su perspectiva parcial lo que
hacen es mostrarnos
que la perspectiva dominante que había
sido la masculina es también una
perspectiva parcial
esto ocurre también por ejemplo en la
paleoantropología donde durante
muchísimo tiempo la hipótesis dominante
fue la hipótesis del hombre cazador o
sea la idea de que los humanos los seres
humanos somos lo que somos porque los
hombres del pasado iban a cazar y por
eso hemos desarrollado el lenguaje el
uso de instrumentos el bipedismo incluso
adrián silva nancy tanner salí slocum
ellas muestran el sesgo de la hipótesis
del hombre cazador proponiendo la
hipótesis de la mujer recolectora dicen
no no somos lo que somos porque los
hombres del pasado fueran a cazar somos
lo que somos porque las mujeres del
pasado criaban y recolectaban bueno esta
teoría estaba bien respaldada por la
evidencia empírica pero fue no fue en
absoluto aceptada por la comunidad
científica porque su evidente
parcialidad era demasiado obvia pero lo
que hizo esta evidente parcialidad fue
poner de manifiesto que la perspectiva
que había sido dominante era también una
perspectiva parcial pero una parcialidad
que había estado oculta y que había
estado invisibilizada en arqueología
psicología antropología sociología en
todas estas disciplinas
ejemplos a través de los cuales las
científicas nos demuestran que los
estereotipos de género tienen una
grandísima fuerza para definir aquello
que aceptamos como verdadero y también
incluso hay otras disciplinas como la
medicina en la que se muestra esta cera
era de género por ejemplo la idea de que
el varón es el individuo universal de la
especie humana obstaculizó durante mucho
tiempo la investigación sobre las
peculiaridades la enfermedad
cardiovascular en las mujeres excluidas
de los ensayos clínicos porque somos
sujetos inestables todo el conocimiento
sobre el diagnóstico y el tratamiento de
la enfermedad coronaria se montó sobre
datos obtenidos con los varones cuando
la epidemiología lo que nos dice la
epidemiología es que las mujeres es que
en la enfermedad coronaria es una causa
muy importante de muerte en las mujeres
aunque quizás sería más adecuado decir
que la causa de la muerte de muchas de
estas mujeres fue más bien la ignorancia
la ignorancia acerca de la
sintomatología específica acerca de los
factores de riesgo o acerca de la la
eficacia y la seguridad de los
medicamentos en su tratamiento como
mujer con las mujeres
en definitiva lo que se decide ignorar
es tan importante como lo que se decide
conocer en la ciencia y en estas
decisiones los científicos y las
científicas las toman condicionados por
sus propias situaciones parciales que
condicionan las preguntas que se
formulan los métodos que se utilizan los
datos que se consideran relevantes y las
preguntas que son aceptables y que son
aceptadas tendemos a ver y escuchar
aquello que mejor encaja con lo que
creemos saber o con lo que de hecho
sabemos y por eso estos ejemplos lo que
nos muestran es que la perspectiva y el
punto de vista es muy importante de
todos modos la perspectiva de las
mujeres no es más objetiva que la
perspectiva de los hombres pero sí
contribuye a una mayor objetividad al
poner de manifiesto aquello que había
estado oculto que es en este caso que el
punto de vista masculino es un punto de
vista parcial por eso quizá el valor más
importante para la objetividad
científica sea el de la pluralidad
porque una ciencia más plural es una
ciencia que está mejor preparada para
identificar aquellos puntos ciegos
provocados por una única
parcial dominante una ciencia más plural
entonces será una ciencia más robusta
porque como decía a richard levin las
verdades que aceptamos son la
intersección de mentiras independientes